While there is no single correct way to walk,
most of us have a gait where we swing each
arm forward when its opposing leg moves forward;
likewise, as with the length of the stride,
which is generally the same for both legs,
the distance of the arm swing is usually about
the same for both the left and right arms.
While exactly why humans do this hasn’t
yet been definitively proven (with the most
popular theory being that, while not essential,
it’s mostly about improving balance and
decreasing angular momentum of the body),
the fact remains that this is how the vast
majority of humans all over the world walk…
But not so with Vladimir Putin, President
of the Russian Federation.
For those who’ve never seen Putin’s rather
odd walk, as is more common, when Putin walks,
his left arm swings freely forward with his
right leg stride.
However, when his left leg strides forward,
his right arm barely moves at all, remaining
nearly still and close to his torso.
This has resulted in some idly speculating
that maybe there is some neurological cause
for the gait, perhaps even a sign of Putin
being in the early stages of Parkinson’s
disease, as reduced arm swing is a potential
early indicator (though generally with tremors
in the limb or other such additional indicators
as well).
(Incidentally: The Man Who Parkinson’s Disease
is Named After Was Implicated in a Plot to
Assassinate King George III.)
Others have speculated Erb’s palsy or even
a minor stroke might be the underlying cause.
The problem with all of these hypotheses is
that Putin not only has full use of his right
arm and hand for day to day activities like
writing, eating, etc., but even likes to show
off his prodigious Judo skills, as well as
strength in weightlifting.
In both cases, the right hand and arm seemingly
show no sign of weakness, tremors, etc.
Combined with the fact that Putin’s had
this gait for many years without change, this
all seemingly rules out any of the aforementioned
potential causes.
So what’s going on?
Well, thankfully as Putin himself has never
commented on it as far as we can find, a team
of doctors, led by movement disorder specialist
Dr. Bastiaan Bloem, decided to look into the
matter, publishing their paper on the subject
in the British Medical Journal in 2015.
In it, they came up with an intriguing and
quite probable hypothesis as to why Putin
walks this way.
In their paper, titled “Gunslinger’s gait”:
a new cause of unilaterally reduced arm swing,
They noted that Putin was once a long-time
member of the Soviet Union security agency
known as the KGB (1975-1991).
(In fact, he eventually rose to the rank of
Lieutenant Colonel within that organization
before leaving it during the brief August
Coup attempt against President Mikhail Gorbachev.)
Showing off their research skills, the doctors
dug up the book, KGB Alpha Team training manual,
which, if you go read through that manual,
contains the following text (Chapter 2) concerning
the proper way to move:
…it is absolutely necessary to keep your
weapon against the chest or in the right hand.
Moving forward should be done with one side,
usually the left, turned somewhat in the direction
of movement.
You should crouch to stay concealed.
Lean the body forward slight and keep the
knees bent.
While Putin forgoes crouching and the like
when walking around in public, his gait otherwise
very much mimics the one recommended in the
training manual, with presumably his right
hand staying mostly stationary at his side
holding an imaginary gun or otherwise prepared
to draw such a non-existent weapon at need.
In other words, perhaps because it was so
grilled into him in training, or simply because
he thinks it looks cool when he’s walking
with that so-called “gunslinger’s gait,”
he seems to have chosen to keep the walk long
after his KGB days ended.
Now, on its own this reference in the training
manual doesn’t definitively prove anything.
It’s still just speculation by the doctors
in question.
To give more credence to their hypothesis,
the researchers presumed that if it was really
the KGB training that cause this peculiar
walk, Putin wouldn’t be the only one that
walked this way.
Thus, they examined the walks of other Russian
military and/or former KGB officers, finding
several Russian officials today that also
displayed the seemingly bizarre walk.
Most notable among this group are Prime Minister
Dmitry Medvedev, former ministers of defense
Anatoly Serdyukov and Sergei Ivanov, and a
military commander of high rank, Anatoly Sidorov.
Like Putin, Ivanov was a KGB official, and
thus this seemingly supported the hypothesis
that strict adherence to KGB training led
to Putin’s now lifelong habit of walking
with one arm more or less fixed at his side
and body ever so slightly turned.
In addition, although not KGB, Sidorov was
a member of the Russian military and Serdyukov
had served at least one year in the Soviet
Army where this particular type of movement
was similarly taught.
In all of these cases, these individual’s
walks aren’t quite as extreme as Putin’s
can sometimes be, but they definitely display
the same basic pattern of movement.
The one that doesn’t fit the mold, however,
is Medvedev, who has no direct links to the
military or intelligence services, but still
walks this way at times.
That said, in his case, he seems to have very
actively been coached to mimic Putin’s iconic
walk, expressions, and even speech patterns
during the process of being groomed to potentially
follow Putin as President, which he subsequently
did from 2008-2012.
Of course, without confirmation from Putin
himself, nobody can really know why he walks
this way, but given the lack of any other
signs of a neurological issue that might cause
such a gait, that the movement pattern is
described well in the KGB training manual,
and that at least some other ex-KGB operatives
also display a similar walk, this certainly
seems like the most compelling hypothesis
anyone’s come up with so far.